cette réunion qui avait été demandée
pour les syndicats et puis que lyon
qu'on voulait déjà faire aussi
malheureusement avec les problèmes de
lune glacée tous les tous les arriérés
que nous avions nous pouvions pas être
pour répondre au jour le jour d'avant
répondu aujourd'hui nous sommes venus
nous avons répondu aux questions j'ai
l'impression que le syndic a bien
compris l'enjeu et nous sommes prêts à
continuer à travailler pour sur les
dossiers de l'université je pense que
c'est une bonne manière de d'aborder les
problèmes de l'université s'il faut
qu'il y ait un dialogue social que nous
allons continuer c'est un plat simple
continuant ce dialogue social il ya des
volontés de séparation des velléités
d'indépendance
est ce raisonnable pour le pôle antilles
si tel pourrait être le cas je dirais
c'est une dizaine très très mauvaise
chose pour notre université
il ne faudrait il faudrait pas arrivé à
ce stade je sais pas si vraiment les
gens sont centrés sur cette séparation
si tel était le cas nous serions à deux
petites universités de collège avec des
diplômes qui ne seraient pas visibles au
plan national et international
notre cher ne soit pas visible en plus
je crois ce qu'il faut militer pour
vraiment véritablement une université
une et indivisible campus m ensemble
nous faut sauver et réduit nos
faiblesses de manière à ce que nos
formations soient adéquates l'option
garder nos étudiants que les familles
prennent confiance en nous pouvoir
inscrire leurs enfants dans notre
université avec des formations
innovantes et une recherche de qualité
financièrement quelle est la réalité de
cette université actuellement nous avons
de grosses difficultés financières mais
nous avons une gestion fine espérons ne
pas du tout un havre pour s'inquiéter
sur le sur les primes du personnel et le
paiement du personnel
mais qui cela veut dire que la la
la gestion doit être très très très fine
jean-noël pour être extrêmement
extrêmement vigilant vous confirmez que
vous êtes un président à l'écouté de
paul pour la guadeloupe et martinique
alors je dis et je redis qu'il ya une
seule université il ya deux pôles mais
ce qui se fait au niveau des deux points
c'est exactement la même chose cela veut
dire que quand le président donne une
information il la donne en même temps
sur les deux pôles
maintenant au niveau de chaque poule il
ya des deux vice présidents il ya des
élus les élus doivent mettre en action
ce qui a été décidé au niveau central
tout en sachant que le président ne
décide pas seul il travaille avec des
conseils dont le conseil
d'administration